[Applause]
uh
bradley
uh we have another special guest today
doesn't sing as well as our guest from
yesterday
but very knowledgeable
today uh we have a special guest a
surgeon general vivek
murthy the surgeon general has been one
of our leading voices on public health
in the administration in particular
around the covid19 response
today he published an advisory on health
misinformation as an urgent public
health crisis and he's here to talk more
about this issue
and take a few of your questions with
that i will turn it over
hello everyone how are you it's nice to
see you all today and thank you jen for
that very kind introduction
as all of you know we've come a long way
in our fight against covet 19
and we've come a long way thanks to the
efforts of many many people
across the united states right now
we are covet debts markedly down for
peak in january
we have 160 million people who have been
fully vaccinated
and hundreds of thousands of people each
day are choosing to get vaccinated
that is all good news but we are not out
of the woods yet
millions of americans are still not
protected against cobit 19
and we are seeing more infections among
those who are unvaccinated
and that's why i want to talk to you
today about one of the biggest obstacles
that's preventing us from ending this
pandemic
today i issued a surgeon general's
advisory
on the dangers of health misinformation
student general advisories are reserved
for urgent public health threats
and while those threats have often been
related to what we eat
drink and smoke today we live in a world
where misinformation poses an imminent
and insidious threat to our nation's
health
health misinformation is false
inaccurate or
misleading information about health
according to the best evidence at the
time
and while it often appears innocuous on
social media apps on retail sites or
search engines
the truth is that misinformation takes
away our freedom
to make informed decisions about our
health and the health of our loved ones
during the covet 19 pandemic health
misinformation has led people
to resist wearing masks in high risk
settings
it's led them to turn down proven
treatments and to choose not to get
vaccinated
this has led to avoidable illnesses in
depth
simply put health information has cost
us
lives now health misinformation didn't
start with covet 19 what's different now
though
is this speed and scale at which health
misinformation is spreading
modern technology companies have enabled
misinformation to poison our information
environment with little accountability
to their users
they've allowed people to intentionally
spread misinformation what we call
disinformation to have extraordinary
reach
they've designed product features such
as like buttons
that reward us for sharing emotionally
contact
not accurate content and their
algorithms tend to give
us more of we click on pulling us deeper
and deeper into a well
of misinformation now we need an all of
society approach
to fight misinformation and that's why
this advisory that i issue today
has recommendations for everyone first
we include recommendations for
individuals and families
we ask people to raise the bar for
sharing health information by checking
sources before they share to ensure that
information is backed by credible
scientific sources as we say in the
advisory
if you are not sure don't share
second we're asking health organizations
to proactively address misinformation
with their patients
hey the american academy of pediatrics
is announcing educational campaign
to help parents navigate online health
information
i'm encouraged to see the commitment and
again this is just the beginning
third we're asking educational
institutions to help improve
health information literacy we're asking
researchers and foundations as well to
help us
learn more about how health information
spreads and how to stop it
today the rockefeller foundation is
announcing a 13.5 million dollar
commitment
to counter health misinformation the
digital public library of america is
announcing that they will convene
a set of librarians scholars journalists
and civic leaders
to confront health misinformation
together
fourth we are saying we expect more from
our technology companies
we're asking them to operate with
greater transparency and accountability
we're asking them to monitor
misinformation more closely
we're asking them to consistently take
action against misinformation super
spreaders on their platforms
fifth we're also asking news
organizations to proactively address the
public's questions
without inadvertently giving a platform
to help misinformation that can harm
their audiences
and sixth we know that government can
play an important role too
by investing in research by bringing
individuals and organizations together
to dismiss information and supporting
groups that are working on this issue
on a personal note uh it's painful for
me to know
that nearly every death we are seeing
now from kobe 19
could have been prevented i say that as
someone who has lost
10 family members to covet 19 and who
wishes
each and every day that they had had the
opportunity to get vaccinated
i say that also as a concerned father of
two young children who aren't yet
eligible for the vaccine
but i know that our kids are depending
on all of us to get vaccinated
to shield them from this virus every
week
i talk to doctors and nurses across our
country who are burning
out as they care for more and more
patients with covid19 who never got
vaccinated
all too often because they were misled
by misinformation
we must confront misinformation as a
nation
every one of us has the power and the
responsibility to make a difference in
this fight
lives are depending on it you can read
the full advisory
at surgeon general dot gov forward slash
health misinformation
and i hope that you will see it as i do
as a starting point from which we can
build
a healthier information environment
safeguard our nation against future
threats
and ultimately empower people to lead
healthier lives
thanks so much for your time and
alternative
i wanted to ask you whether you see any
evidence at all that the misinformation
and disinformation
that you're seeing comes from any
nefarious sources are you seeing
sort of structures behind the scenes
that point to
who or what might be behind that we've
seen russian disinformation in the past
we've seen
kind of that hybrid warfare are you
seeing any indication that there could
be
nation states behind this misinformation
well andrew thank you for the question
the misinformation that we're seeing
comes from multiple
sources yes there is disinformation that
is coming from
bad actors but what is also important to
point out is that much of the
misinformation that is circulating
online is often coming from individuals
who don't have bad intentions but who
are unintentionally
sharing information that they think
might be helpful and that's why in this
advisory
we make it very clear that among the
things we're asking individuals to do
is to pause before they share to check
sources and if they're not sure if a
source is credible
to not share you know one of the things
we have said again is that when it comes
to misinformation
not sharing is caring unlike what many
of our moms taught us
earlier you very much
surgeon general is misinformation the
number one reason why people are not
getting vaccinated
well caitlyn it's one of several reasons
why people are not getting vaccinated
but it's a very important one because
what we know from polls caitlyn is that
two-thirds of people who are not
vaccinated either believe common myths
about the kobe 19 vaccine or think
some of those myths might be true myths
like you can get covid
from the vaccine which is absolutely not
true so we know that it's not the only
driver
that's leading people not to be
vaccinated but it is a very important
one
and do you personally believe that
public figures and public companies that
are helping spread
misinformation about the vaccine should
be held accountable
well i think in a moment like this when
we see misinformation literally
costing us our loved ones costing us
lives
all of us have to ask how we can be more
accountable and responsible
for the information that we share and
those of us who may have larger
platforms
i think bear a greater responsibility to
think about that
but the bottom line is all of us have an
important role here to play
and technology companies uh have a
particularly important role
we know that the dramatic increase in
this feel speed and scale of spread of
misinformation has in part been enabled
by these platforms so that's why in this
advisory today
we are asking them to step up we know
they have taken some steps to address
misinformation
but much much more has to be done and we
can't wait
longer for them to take aggressive
action because it's costing people their
lives
so the reality is a lot of the health
misinformation
you were citing came from this lecture
in last year i mean what do you think
the best approach is
to counter or deal with misinformation
that comes from
public officials people in position of
authority
well what i would say is that when it
comes to determining what is accurate in
terms of health information
science has to guide us and the good
news is that we have
credible science individuals in our
country we have doctors and nurses in
communities we have public health
departments
and the cdc we have medical schools
nursing schools and healthcare
institutions
these should be our sources of
credibility when it comes to evaluating
whether information is true or not
i think one of the greatest roles that
public leaders can play is to point to
scientists
and to credible sources and have them
speak directly to the public
i'll note for you that that's one thing
that this administration has done
is work hard to put science scientists
and health care professionals
in front of cameras to be having to
speak directly to the public
that's what we have to do more of the
problem right now is that the voices of
these credible health professionals
are getting drowned out and that's one
of the reasons we are asking technology
companies
to help lift up the voices of credible
health authorities it's also why they
have to do more to reduce
the misinformation that's out there so
that the true voices of experts can
shine through
rachel thank you so much for taking my
question um so are there specific
elected leaders that you believe
are part of the problem with pushing
this misinformation
and we had an abc news washington post
poll that showed that 93
of democrats say they're vaccinated or
will be vaccinated but only 49
of republicans say the same so how do
you break through to the people who may
be trusting some of these elected
uh leaders that are pushing maybe some
of this misinformation more than they
actually trust members of your own
administration
well thanks rachel you know i think
about this as i as i think about
doctoring and as i think about my
approach to patients which is i
recognize that
each patient that i was blessed to care
for is an individual
you know regardless of what their
political affiliation or their past may
be
uh they're an individual and i my goal
was to understand what their needs and
desires were what their values were
and then to help them improve their
health we have to take a similar
approach here when it comes to reaching
people with information about kobit 19
and the vaccine
you've got to recognize that sometimes
the most trusted voices are not
the ones that have the most followers on
social media or the ones that have
the most you know name recognition
sometimes the most trusted sources are
a mother or father or a faith leader or
a local doctor
or a nurse and that's why to reach
people with accurate information what we
have to do
is partner with those local trusted
voices
that's why in this advisory one of the
things that we point out an important
role for government
is to support local organizations
including healthcare professionals
so that they can get out there and speak
directly to people and share that
information
these public health efforts move at the
speed of trust
and we have to recognize where trust is
you know where those relationships are
invest in them support them so that
people can ultimately get
the information they need to improve
their health thank you so much
okay i think we're getting ready to
start the briefing i think everybody has
a lot of questions so why don't
why don't you we we we're gonna proceed
with the briefing and
then we're happy to take lots of
questions in the room okay
so um unemployment claims uh which you
all saw the data come out
this morning today's data on new
unemployment claims is further proof
than the
that the president's economic plan is
working today mark did another new
pandemic low an initial unemployment
claims
the lowest level since march of 2020 and
the four-week average of new claims
continued to decline
dropping to its lowest level in 16
months
down 55 percent since when president
biden took
office this is evidence of the
strengthening labor market we're seeing
across the economy
unemployment is down wages are up and
three million new jobs have been created
in five
months the fastest rate in u.s history
we just gave you a few headlines over
here just in case you haven't read
all of your own coverage and because of
the president's rescue plan
and his work curbing the pandemic the
united states is expected to return to
full employment
by next year instead of 2024 which was
the projection when the president
first took office another piece of news
today
we heard the president of course
announce today that 15 billion dollars
in child tax credit payments
uh were distributed tens of millions of
families covering
60 million children working families
will receive these payments on the 15th
of every single month for the next year
thanks to the american rescue plan
86 of american families will receive
their payment by
direct deposit it will show up in their
bank accounts as
child ctc others will receive their
check in the mail today or in the next
few days and just as a reminder the
american rescue plan is providing the
largest ever child
tax credit and this is a historic
increase that will provide
middle class families with critical tax
relief and many
project it will help cut the child
poverty rate in half
i have a little update for all of you on
ransomware as well as
vaccines and then we'll get to your
questions in april the president
directed agencies to take aggressive
action to counter the ransomware
threat at home and abroad we have
coordinated
these efforts regularly convening an
interagency task force
that drives coordinated whole of
government action to counter ransomware
participation spans the whole government
including law enforcement
the intelligence community center risk
management agencies
regulators and other national security
agencies
today as a part of our ongoing
ransomware efforts the department of
homeland security
department of justice treasury and state
announced new resources
and initiatives to protect american
businesses and communities from
ransomware attacks those include the
department of homeland security and the
department of justice
launched stop ransomware.gov a
coordinated federal government one-stop
resource for public and private sector
organizations
to reduce their risk of ransomware
attacks the department of treasury
announced a fincent exchange on
ransomware to discuss efforts by the
public and private sectors
to increase targeted information sharing
and analysis and pursue
criminal actors and networks that engage
in such attacks
and the department of state announced it
will offer up to 10 million dollars in
rewards
for information leading to the
identification or location of any person
engaged in state-sponsored malicious
cyber
activities this is a part of our ongoing
efforts and our ongoing
work of our interagency process that is
a new
a newer initiative in this
administration finally last night haiti
received 500 000 doses of covet 19
moderna vaccines donated by the united
states
through the kovacs facility and we will
send in a significant amount of
additional doses to haiti soon
in consultation with local health
authorities the embassy in haiti
has worked closely with haitian health
the haitian health ministry
pan-american health organization and
unicef to ensure that these vaccines
arrive
safely and securely and that they are
also distributed
equitably and without interference uh to
the people who need them most
uh remain of course a partner of the
haitian people and building a more
stable
and secure haiti including in its fight
against cleveland 19 go ahead alex
thanks jen
can you talk a little bit more about
this request for tech companies to be
more aggressive in policing
misinformation has the administration
been in touch with any of these
companies and
are there any actions that the federal
government can take to ensure their
cooperation because we've seen
from the start there's not a lot of
action on some of these platforms
sure uh well first we are in regular
touch uh with
these social media platforms uh and
those engagements typically happen
through members of our senior staff
but also members of our covid19 team
given as
dr murthy uh conveyed this is a big
issue of misinformation specifically on
the pandemic
in terms of actions alex that we have
taken or we're working to take i should
say
from the federal government we've
increased disinformation research and
tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts
for facebook that spreads this
information
we're working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect
uh two connected medical experts with
popular with popular who are popular
with their audiences with
uh with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping
get trusted content out there we also
created the covid19
the covid community core to get factual
information into the hands
of local messengers and we're also
investing as you'll have seen in the
presidents the vice presidents and dr
fauci's time in meeting
with influencers who also have large
reaches to a lot of these target
audiences
who can spread and share accurate
information you saw an example of that
uh yesterday i believe that video will
be out for tomorrow i think that was
your question steve yesterday
the full follow-up there um there are
also proposed changes that we have made
to social media platforms including
facebook
and those specifically are four key
steps one
uh that they measure and publicly share
the impact of misinformation on their
platform
facebook should provide publicly and
transparently data on the reach of covet
19
covet vaccine misinformation not just
engagement
but the reach of the misinformation and
the audience that it's reaching that
will help us ensure we're getting
accurate information to people
this should be provided not just to
researchers but to the public
so that the public knows and understands
what is accurate and inaccurate
second uh that we have recommended uh
proposed that they create a robust
enforcement strategy
that bridges their properties and
provides transparency about the rules
so about i think this was a question
asked before there's about 12 people who
are producing 65
of anti-vaccine misinformation on social
media platforms
all of them remain active on facebook
despite some even being banned on other
platforms including facebook
ones that facebook owns third it's
important to take faster action against
harmful posts as you all know
information travels quite quickly on
social media platforms
sometimes it's not accurate and facebook
needs to move more quickly to remove
harmful
violative posts posts that will be
within their policies for removal often
remain up for days
that's too long the information spreads
too quickly finally
we have proposed they promote quality
information sources in their feed
algorithm facebook has repeatedly shown
that they have the levers to promote
quality information we've seen them
effectively
do this in their algorithm over low
quality information and they've chosen
not to use it in this case
and that's certainly an area that would
have an impact so these are
certainly the proposals uh we engage
with them regularly and they certainly
understand what our asks are
and one of the problems with vaccines
right now is that they become
politicized
um you guys the white house has
obviously made the calculation that it's
important to be more aggressive
in confronting this information but is
there at all a concern that that could
backfire and further contribute to
politicization and is there anything
that you can do to prevent that at this
point
well you're actually you're absolutely
right i should say alex and that we
have to be very careful and we are
mindful of being quite careful of not
politicizing
uh the effectiveness of vaccines the
fact that they can save lives
young people old people middle of the
road people
it's important for us we've made a
calculation to push back on
misinformation you're right
but that's one of the reasons as dr
murthy was conveying we have empowered
engaged
funded local voices because they are
often the most trusted voices
doctors medical experts clergy uh
you know people who are members of civic
leaders and communities
that's where we are putting most of our
resources even as we are
working to combat misinformation that's
traveling online or traveling
unfortunately out of the mouths of
elected officials uh from time to time
go ahead
follow up on the run on the uh
ransomware sure question
so the president told us last week that
there's this meeting tomorrow
of the u.s russian uh working group on
ransomware can you say a little bit more
about that was actually yesterday
okay can you give us any kind of a
further readout of what decisions were
made if any
last week the president also said that
it made sense to potentially go after
servers
that were being used in these ransomware
attacks as the administration made any
decisions about whether to proceed with
that kind of action
so i would say that the meeting which i
believe was yesterday i will double
confirm for you andrea and for others
but
is part of ongoing engagement that has
been occurring
at the expert level since the president
met with president putin so it's been
ongoing
no one meeting is necessarily decisive
it's about
having a continued discussion about our
expectations and steps that need to be
taken
to address ransomware attacks cyber
attacks
and what the capacities are and
information of course that we have
in terms of specific actions the
president of course reserves uh the
right and the option to respond in a
time in a manner of his choosing
uh should he believe actions warrants
but i'm not going to preview that from
the podium today or
probably any day go ahead so a senior
administration official had told us in
the aftermath of that
conversation that we should expect
action within days and weeks and some of
it would be visible some of it would not
be visible
i understand that you can't share
a lot of information but can you say
whether any action has
in fact been taken that perhaps is not
visible to us there's nothing more i can
preview or detail for you from here
certainly understand the interest go
ahead
the president has designated 10 billion
for testing in schools
but we've seen some states like idaho
and iowa they say they don't even want
the money
so is that a mistake and who should be
held responsible if
children in those schools get sick well
certainly we've always said from the
beginning that local school districts
are going to make decisions
about how to use the funding and
resources available but also
how they're going to apply uh the
mitigation measures that have been laid
out
by the cdc and certainly we would expect
that
members of their local community parents
others who care about the health and
well-being of their children would voice
their concern if they have it but
it's always worked that way in terms of
local school districts implementing
policies
the role of the cdc is to provide public
health
information our role from the federal
government was to secure funding to
ensure schools that need resources
they don't all need resources but have
access to those funds should they need
it
many have used it many have applied it
and many schools will be opening as a
result
of that funding is there a concern
though about not being able to even
track an
outbreak if there is one because of the
lack of testing possibly
well we certainly the cdc certainly does
track where there is a rise in cases as
you see they put out publicly
available data i expect they would
continue to do that
but i would point you to them for more
information on how they would track
i just have one could follow up on
inflation we heard from
the fed chair jerome powell and he's
testifying on capitol hill this week he
noted that inflation has notably
uh increased but he believes that it
will remain elevated in the coming
months and
before moderating um we've heard from
republicans who say the administration
is sort of flooding the economy
with cash even democrats like senator
joe manchin i talked to him yesterday he
says that he has concerns about
inflation
is the white house underestimating the
impact of all of this government
spending that it will have on inflation
well our experts believe and the data
shows and the federal reserve chair who
operates independently
conveyed yesterday that most of the
price increases
we are seeing are expected to be
temporary due to the consequences of
restarting an economy
shut down during the pandemic and we're
seeing that in certain industries
more than others as prices go back to
where they were pre-pandemic and that
certainly
uh was an ex we had an expectation that
would be an impact so
areas like spike in car prices due to
supply chain challenges on the
on the restart or spike in hotel room
costs as the hospitality industry gets
going
these are a number of these are
transitory or they're impacted by other
factors including supply chain issues
which we're working with
democrats and republicans to help
address through the chips legislation
but i want to be clear we take we
understand the threat that
inflation poses we will be vigilant as
responses are needed
are needed as it relates to legislation
we're continuing to advocate for
the way to keep prices in our economy
down is to increase the supply of goods
that consumers want to buy and keep the
cost of producing
and getting them to market lower that's
exactly what the president's bipartisan
infrastructure framework and the build
back better
plans will do and i would also remind
you all it's an eight-year
investment in better roads bridges and
transit systems so this is not an
immediate influx
in the next few months of funding it's
over the course of several years
because this is a long-term issue and it
will also if
as we as we work to pass the build back
better reconciliation package
increase the availability of child care
more work goes well into the workforce
increasing our output and helping to
keep prices down so we are quite mindful
of it we do
monitor it i would also note the federal
reserve who's independent has also
projected that the inflation
numbers will come down to about 2.2 next
year from where they're projecting for
this year
which is something we also watch closely
go ahead caitlyn go ahead caitlyn are
you confident that the government is
going to be able to find the parents who
qualify for the child tax credit but are
outside of the tax system
well we have a as you've seen as we've
implemented a number of our programs to
date we have a mean a number of means
of trying to identify individuals who
are eligible for these programs
some of it is by promotion in
communities for individuals who may not
have had to pay taxes
or may not be in the system uh and
certainly we will be vigilant and do
everything we can to reach every single
person who's eligible
get out the words of communities uh that
they are that they're maybe people who
are eligible even if they don't make
enough money to pay taxes so what are
the other avenues
specifically that you're using to find
these parents well i think you've seen
us use a number of avenues
in the past few months where there were
not individuals
as it related to our 1400 checks that we
put out just a few months ago
we put out a website where people could
go if they had not
paid taxes because they did not make
enough money to pay taxes
uh we also of course work with local
communities to get out and make sure
get the word out and make sure people
know they are eligible
again i would think i think that
starting today the vast majority vast
vast majority of people who are eligible
of course will get their
checks uh direct through direct deposit
and through direct checks so we're
talking about
a small percentage of individuals who we
would be looking to
find and of course we will be vigilant
about doing everything we can to find
them and one follow-up on that
will the president accept a spending
bill that does not
extend the tax credit for four years
like he wants
there are a range of details i know you
were all eager to see and to have and
there's been reporting about it
we will certainly leave it to leader
schumer and democrats uh on the hill to
put out all of the specific details
but the president certainly understands
that uh there could be changes even to
his original proposal
uh and even from here as the final
negotiations continue
so he would accept that sorry i'm not
going to negotiate from here caitlyn but
we'll look to see what the final
package looks like the president has
advocated for an extension of the child
tax credit because he thinks it is
a benefit that helps working families
that's why he's proposed it in multiple
packages
and we'll look to see the final details
go ahead i know you said this is
moving but um some democrats have
expressed they believe the child tax
credit should be permanent
does president biden agree with that or
does he think the four-year extension
is adequate well as you know he put in
his proposal a five-year extension he
certainly understands that
there was going to be and there was a
range of views some wanted it shorter
some wanted it longer some didn't want
it at all
that's part of the negotiations and the
discussion i think one of the
calculations here that
senators and congress have to work
through is what components
can be worked through that you can pay
for in the package uh
that's a factor as it relates to
certainly to the child tax credit which
as i understand costs about a billion
dollars a year so we'll let them work
out the length of it
and we look forward to seeing the the
final details uh made public in the
coming days
the uh bipartisan bills yeah republicans
have just
um said that it that they're not
prepared to vote
on something that is not written yet
they just expressed this on the hill
senator romney said it would be a
dereliction of duty to vote even
procedurally on something
that has not been written does the
president agree
with senator schumer's timeline to hold
a vote before
all the language is finalized well first
i think it's important to remember that
there was an agreement
uh that many senators were a part of
democrat and republican
on the framework that is the basis of
this piece of legislation
right that they agreed to the president
certainly expects that
everyone will stay true to their
commitment as as he will
uh of course the president believes that
his
most important role he can play is to
continue to advocate for
the key components of what's in this
package why it's important
for people to support it in congress and
why the american people
should be excited about investments in
roads and railways and bridges and
investments in making sure we're
addressing our climate crisis he will
leave the mechanics and the timeline up
to leader schumer
go ahead thank you jen uh now that
you've had a few days to think about it
does this white house still think the
protests in cuba
are happening because people are upset
about a rise in coveted cases there or
is there some thought maybe given to the
possibility
that they are protesting because they
are sick of communism
well uh peter first i would say
communism is a failed
ideology and we certainly believe that
it has failed the people of cuba
they deserve freedom they deserve a
government that supports them
whether that is making sure they have
health and medical
supplies access to vaccines or whether
they have
economic opportunity and prosperity and
instead this has been a government an
authoritarian
communist regime that has repressed its
people
and has failed uh the people of cuba
hence we're seeing them in the streets
but i would note that
the ideology of the government which has
failed
has led to a fail
a lack of access to economic opportunity
to medical
supplies to covet vaccines so all of
those pieces are true
and there are protesters now in this
country who are
chanting as these protests in cuba are
going on where is
biden so where is he what is he doing
to protect these people who are rising
up against the leaders of this field
experiment well first uh he is certainly
advocating for and speaking out as we
put out a statement multiple statements
maybe one of you asked him a question
about cuba today i will
i will leave it to all of you to
determine that uh but
uh one he is made clear that he stands
with the cuban people
and their call for freedom uh from both
the pandemic and from decades of
repression and economic suffering to
which they have been subjected by cuba's
authoritarian regime there's an ongoing
review
of our own policies and as we look at
those policies one of the big factors is
ensuring
we are not doing anything to pad the
pockets of a corrupt
authoritarian regime and that is
certainly a factor as he's
considering but we're looking closely at
how we can help in a humanitarian way
how we can help uh support uh the voices
of the cuban people
and there's an ongoing policy review in
that regard and we'd be happy to ask him
about it later if he
calls on us but one word anyone can ask
anything they want but go ahead
uh why is the secretary of state lincoln
trying to address
human rights in the u.s by inviting
experts um experts from
cuba and china here well first i would
say
um that the secretary put out an
extensive statement on why he is
uh holding why he believes that we need
to play a role in lifting up
and pushing countries to do better on
human rights
on ending systemic racism in their
countries
and certainly human rights is always
going to be a priority for the biden
administration and for this
uh state department uh as the secretary
said in his statement
uh he believes responsible nations must
not shrink from scrutiny of their human
rights record
rather they should acknowledge it with
the intent to improve it and also
push and lift up and and put a shine a
light on other countries that need to do
better and that is the role we're
playing here from the united states
you just rattled off all these problems
with cuba they've got dissenters
disappearing down there
in china they've got a million religious
minorities
in internment camps why are they going
to come here
and tell us how to improve our country i
certainly don't think that's the format
of the event but
uh lifting up and elevating human rights
systemic racism uh the uh the uh
the the steps that have been taken the
poor treatment of uyghurs as i think
you're referencing here in china
uh and and pushing other countries with
a spotlight on them to do better
is certainly a role we can play from the
united states go ahead
ask about south africa very quickly
there's been days there have been days
of looting and unrest there in south
africa they've now destroyed hundreds
of businesses at least 117 people there
have been killed does the white house
have any reaction to what's taking place
there and what if any rule does the u.s
government have here to help try to
quell
the situation uh we certainly uh track
and watch closely and uh or certainly
have concerns about
unrest uh that we see in the streets in
south africa in terms of the specific
actions
i think the state department is probably
best equipped but i'm happy to talk to
our
uh national security team if there's
anything specifically we can convey from
here let me follow up
today i asked you about afghanistan is
there anything more you can tell us
about those special immigrant visas as
they relate to the afghan interpreters
translators engineers and others
sure let me try to provide a little bit
more detail on how the process works
which i you have all understandably been
asking about
uh so as i've noted in the past our
immediate focus
is on interested and eligible afghan
nationals and their families
who have supported the united states and
our partners in afghanistan
and are in the application pipeline so
translators uh interpreters others
their family members who are in the
process there are approximately 20
000 afghans who have applied so those
are the individual interpreters or
translators that does not include their
family members
and about half that have completed the
necessary paperwork
to move forward in the process i believe
also the state department is going to do
a more thorough briefing but i'll just
go through
as many details as i can from here once
individuals see how the process works
once individuals are approved through
the security vetting process
which their paperwork conclusion does
not conclude it there's another vetting
process they would conclude
they may be eligible uh under a
humanitarian parole
under that parole a lot a large portion
of that group could be relocated
directly to a military base
in the united states where they would
receive medical checkups
those who have not yet completed their
background checks would first be
relocated from afghanistan to either a
u.s military base overseas
or to third countries where they will be
safely housed until their visa
processing
is complete and they can be transferred
to the united states i would also note
we are not considering
any location or place for the third
party countries that would not be safe
would not treat them with respect and
not would not ensure
uh that uh they are uh treated uh
humanely through the journey
of their process also on our vetting
process
this is a thorough process there are
some of these individuals who have
completed their paperwork and are in
through the vetting process their family
members may not be in the same stage of
the vetting process so that may have an
impact too
of the timeline and how not the timeline
but of kind of how they're moved
and where they are moved to so and the
third part
the third country move would be
temporary until they finalize their
paperwork
and security uh vetting process is
complete
so that is a little bit more detail on
the process hopefully that helps go
ahead alex
president former president bush
yesterday um
in an interview criticized the
withdrawal and he said he's
very concerned about the afghan women so
what is the us
going to do to ensure the safety of
those women in afghanistan after we
leave
well first i would say that the
president agrees
that we need to ensure we are continuing
to support through humanitarian programs
through security programs
uh the women of afghanistan and we
certainly respect
the right of the former president to
voice his view
on uh on um on afghanistan and the
president's decision
it's not a secret that president biden
and president bush haven't seen eye to
eye on matters relating to the use of
military
force so we respect his right to voices
opinion we just disagree
uh i would also note that well
we continue uh to provide security
humanitarian assistance we also intend
to have a diplomatic presence
on the ground uh to continue to be a
source and resource for
uh individuals in afghanistan just
secondly senator manchin
is quite upset about some of the climate
provisions in the
3.5 trillion uh package
uh is the white house reaching out to
him is it is the white house prepared to
move off of some of that
lessen the uh some of those provisions
well um
we of course are in touch with senator
manchin i can assure you as we are in
touch with a number of senators
uh who will be who have been pivotal
partners and will continue to be
moving forward i think there was uh one
of the
the concerns i i think i saw expressed
but tell me if this is what you're
asking about is fossil fuels is that the
specific
piece so um well of course the
paint the plan and the package will go a
long way
in addressing the climate crisis and
that is a huge priority to the president
ensuring that these tax credits are in
the reconciliation
bill which is something that did not
make it into the bipartisan deal is
something the president has advocated
for and we're eager of course to pivot
to a clean
energy future we don't intend to do so
uh just
by just by banning fossil fuels or
leaving any working community behind
and what we would certainly convey to
any concerned
individuals is that president biden has
formed an interagency working group to
mobilize federal investments to support
hard-hit coal
oil and gas and power plant communities
across the country that working group
has already identified 38 billion in
existing federal resources
that could be accessed by communities we
don't want to lose leave communities
behind
we still think we can move forward in
addressing our climate crisis squad
stephen
first day of your presidency
congratulations i think i don't know if
it's congratulations seems hard to me go
ahead
i wanted to ask a follow-up to alex's
question that is how does the president
see his role
in the negotiation on the reconciliation
bill is he
an intermediary between some of the more
liberal elements of his party and
senator manchin is he a closer is he
directly involved in this and he went up
to capitol hill yesterday
what's he going to be doing in the weeks
ahead he's going to be available for
whatever is needed to get these bills
across the finish line
and a lot of the discussions are
happening certainly at a staff level
as you all know we have a number of very
experienced uh
individuals here who have gotten a lot
of bills across the finish line steve
richetti
ron claine louisa terrell and many
beyond them
they are playing a big role brian diese
in discussing
and having conversations with members a
lot of the discussions though are
primarily between the democratic members
themselves about
what the final package and the final
details look like leader schumer and his
team will put out the final details
on on the timeline uh that works for
them but i will tell you the president
is available he's ready he's pick up the
phone he'll host people
have snacks drinks whatever is needed in
order to get these bills
across the finish line and i think
leaders in congress certainly know that
uh okay brian thank you very much two
questions one to follow up on the
inflation inflation starts to 5.4 in
june's largest jump
since 2008 you all say it's temporary
but today axios is reporting
that jp morgan chase ceo is saying i
don't think it's only temporary
and that it's a little worse than the
fed predicts
there's a disparity there how are you
going to address what they think may be
permanent
well i would say first that many outside
experts including the federal reserve
even if
jp morgan or jamie dimon or whomever it
is
disagrees have projected that uh the um
that uh the rise of inflation is
transitory and have projected
a uh lowering of inflation next year
uh we also have seen in the data that
some of the issues and i'll outline this
a little bit earlier
like the spike in car prices which we
know has a bigger issue
has another issue involved in it which
is the supply chain issues which we're
trying to separately address
or hotels and some of the um of the
industries that related to travel that
have seen increases
because the economy is turning back on
so uh we certainly will
refer to uh economic experts out there
the federal reserve and many others who
have projected
the transitory nature of this as well as
uh what we see as a number of the
factors that are
leading to the impact currently the
second question is about jeff flake
earlier this week he was uh nominated by
a president to go
to turkey as as our envoy that
ambassadorship is
that's a problematic area what is it
exactly in in the former senator's
background that gives this
uh administration confidence that he can
carry out
his task there well he's a former member
of the senate foreign relations
committee
someone who played an important role in
discussing
uh debating uh and uh and working on a
range of foreign policy issues as in his
role as a
former u.s senator so that is a pretty
good basis okay francesca go ahead i
have a foreign policy question sure
to stay on inflation for a moment what
is the white house's
message to average americans including
those who are on limited income though
who are experiencing
higher prices right now for food and
clothing and
other goods and services you mentioned
that it's expected to die down
next year but but what is your message
to them in the meantime is it simply
just to wait it out
that's certainly not what i've ever said
but um i will say our message is
uh that we understand the threat that
inflation
poses we will be vigilant about any
responses needed
it's important for americans to know and
understand that these impacts are
temporary and some of these
price increases are as are a result of
the economy turning back on
and experts will tell you that whether
it's the hotel industry or the airline
industry going back to pre-pandemic
prices i also know that the president
has taken a number of steps
including ensuring that the vast
majority of the american people were
getting 1400
checks getting the child tax credit out
to people's
uh bank accounts today uh because he
knows that americans need a little extra
help
uh still need a little extra help as the
economy turns back on so
he's committed to helping working people
and it's also important for people
understand the transitory nature of
inflation
and can you provide a status update on
investigative assistance for haiti and
also
when can the public expect the
administration to make a determination
on whether it's changing its policy
towards cuba sure i don't have anything
for you
on the timeline on uh cuba policy i will
note that
uh we certainly look at the policy
through the prism of how we can most
help
the cuban people that people who have
been
out in the streets looking to have their
voices
heard in these protests and even as we
look at individual components of
policies that would be under
consideration including say remittances
there are a range of factors uh there
are a number of course of people who
have called for
a return for allowing remittances to go
from family members to individuals in
cuba uh
on the flip side of that or one of the
challenges is the prevention
or our desire to prevent remittances or
any funding
going in the hands or the pockets of
leaders in cuba
so these are challenging issues there's
an ongoing review
i don't have a timeline to preview for
you in terms of haiti
uh let me see i do think i have a little
bit of an update for you
um let me see what i have for you
so uh we've provided a couple of updates
of what we've provided so
i just in case you don't have this um
the fbi is providing investigative
assistance
to the haitian authorities at the
request of the government of haiti
they remain committed to working
alongside our international partners to
administer
justice that was a specific ask we're
also
continuing to provide uh ongoing
security assistance and
and consultations as they have also
requested uh we're still working with
leaders in haiti
uh to refine their requests and that
review is ongoing we're in regular touch
and as we have additional components to
provide we'll share that with all of you
thank you
okay let's go ahead one more one more
two quick ones
i know i we're wrapping it's like a last
one
you want to put a citizenship pathway
into the reconciliation package
is the white house supportive of that
strategy yep
okay and then can i squeeze in my last
one sure that was an easy one go ahead
okay so uh the florida's governor and
some fec commissioner
and miami representatives are calling on
biden to green light a plan that would
allow the deployment of higher altitude
communication balloons to beam internet
into cuba
um is this something the administration
plans to do and if not why not
well the lack of internet access as you
know which is why you're asking is a
huge issue
in cuba and one that is very challenging
for the people of cuba so they can gain
access to accurate information they can
correspond with
family members and others we're
certainly looking at that to see
what can be done uh to address but in
terms of that specific
proposal i don't have an assessment of
that i can see if there's more specifics
on it
okay thanks everyone thanks everyone